everybody gary vaynerchuk for gary
vaynerchuk com you know I love doing
these videos i feel like people get a
lot of value out of them which makes me
feel tremendous i don't think i'm a big
shot or anything for doing them which is
what i'm going a little bit today trying
to think about what kind of videos uh I
want to do and I wanted to do one today
about what I thought made me special
somebody on the phones like you know
you're really special McIver's you know
why do I get so much love because i do
feel i get disproportionate love at some
level in comparison to people that are
out there and I finally like it kind of
hit me on the drive here just like a
couple years ago hell I decided do why I
let me TV I'm like maybe just cuz i
really know who I am like I know on that
big [ __ ] I know I was an F student I
know there's a lot I can't do and I know
what I'm really good at and I focus on
that so that's where I was gonna go I'm
going in a whole different direction
today mot get your zoomin skills ready
MA I didn't even really prep this so
this could suck a little bit but let's
see what's going on here here's what
basically happens are you sure shot
Twitter lot and listen you're about to
see a lot of things you're gonna say I
need to have tweetdeck you're right
you're gonna say I need to have
something to work all these bubbles
there's a million things everybody's
always tell me you're right see I'm not
good at things as busy as I am I'm not
putting myself in position to have
efficient tools I suck anyway so um
anyway I search my name all the time on
search twitter Gary Vee to see what the
conversation is and I just saw on a
little while ago Alex um p gates say a
little while ago other than being a hell
of a Salesman thank you ah someone
please tell me what makes Gary Vee and
then he puts I don't read books by my
books so compelling please a couple
things here first of all true I mean
that's a great call right I'm like my
new book crush its out not let's look
that up uh no it's over here you guys
could see it the bottom line is my new
books coming out I'm putting a lot out
there but I always talk about how I
don't read and that's true I mean listen
Alex and you know this and he's awesome
you'll see what's going on here in a
minute but you know call spade a spade I
can't go up there and say I read Seth
Godin in the world is flat guy cuz I
don't mean any of that stuff nothing
only anything so at the sink joking I'm
putting out content I read Jets insider
I read about the Jets a whole lot i read
old
boxing results so I consume different
kind of media than I put out and I think
a lot of people get confused about
having to read what you put out that is
not a necessity certain people born with
DNA to be able to rock out certain
categories and I feel with marketing
it's just what I know right and so I'm
not compelled to read it because I feel
like it's in here now listen that
doesn't also assume that I know
everything trust me I've learned a lot
by reading the blogosphere sufficient
early on and as a matter of fact I want
to read more because I feel out of loop
sometimes so but I just don't and I want
to call a spade a spade and I hope that
Alex you and I'm some people take this
wrong and I respect that I understand
but it's not hypocritical it's you know
if you like consuming content about the
new world and with details and the most
awesome book ever then maybe you want to
pick it up but you know you know I'm
making a joke the fact of matter is
that's where that comes from but what I
did after that was when Alex said that I
decided to then search his name um
unsearched out twitter to see who was
responding to him because some people
might have not referenced garyvee
because a lot of times you'll find it
funny actually um if people are mad at
you or don't like you they'll not
reference you so what I did was I
searched his name and I found um right
after he put that at g excuse me Gabe k
said uh oh you just opened a really
[ __ ] can of worms see my blog
mentioning the same topic and when I
went to gabe congress uh blog he wrote a
whole thing and he wrote on his blog
which is really nice by the way gave
good job um thursday night was the
kick-off party featuring gary vaynerchuk
anyone who knows me knows I'm not a fan
of Gary there's tons to like and he's
one inspiring bathroom but for one
reason i can't click with him um he
positions himself differently on mine
that he doesn't person which i totally
disagree with gabe but fair enough if
you feel it you're right I'm wrong
customers always right guys I mean
anybody consumer your stuff there right
you need to figure out what you're not
connecting with during his talks Friday
he said he doesn't have the answers and
he told a story that worked for him and
all he can do hope you find what works
for you but online he positions himself
as a role model with all the answers
when in reality he's a wine salesman
like to think of myself is a little bit
online sales them up but you know
respect that key and and by the way it's
true I mean do I feel that I can go into
any single person's business that's
watching this right now and help it grow
I do not I do I flat up do I can crush
it but I understand I also don't want to
come across as a douche bag which I can
at times and I don't say oh my god I can
do anything for you I've got all the
answers cuz nobody has all answers I
don't feel like a position myself that
way but I respect that cuz that's how he
feels I think Gary would be the first to
agree that that's not cool and you're
right I would um actually I might have
jumped at all all he is a wine sales
when he gives an idea online many people
jump at it believing that it's
spontaneous ideas are somehow better
than their own and I think Gary would be
the first to say that's not cool I I do
feel that I have some marketing ideas
that might be better than other people
so I consoled for a lot of people that
are very very smart and they think
they're good ideas but I verse nobody's
coming from I like his tone on it after
seeing him in person he wants people to
succeed based on what they want not
because they copied verbatim what he has
to say I believe he means well but it's
hard to be an online personality and
also say I have no idea at the same time
Gabe that's where i'm probably not doing
a good enough job i'm not saying i have
no idea i'm saying i don't have the time
to look at every single person's idea
and if i did i guarantee i could help
people get their businesses get their
brands get there but I wish already
coming from isla bring this up because
during the awesome speaker panel he told
the crowd to quit college and it's an
outdated institution that's going down
Jason fleet said the next big bubble to
burst was education I sent out a tweet
saying it's probably the first thing
I've ever agreed with coming from Gary
Gary replied be a Twitter with a smile I
was looking at my Twitter during our
panel up there and I did see that he
then mentioned my comment during his
talk which I did he's bummed when people
have problems with him I found him at
the party that night he looked like he
had his hit playful a lot of people
coming around I guess so I left it at
that so all in all I learned Gary
Vaynerchuk is human which very true but
I still think he's a salesman who
doesn't have all the answers I mean I'm
a Salesman amongst other things but I
definitely don't have it all the answers
and I think he's right in a lot of ways
at the same token i hope i defined what
I think they're I mean I think there's
some guards to what I say I don't repeat
stuff all that much but I totally get
where he's coming from I read that and
what I did off of that now I'm why you
to follow what i did this is important
a lot of brands and a lot of personal
brands a lot of corporations out there
lot of celebrity Twitter's pay attention
what's happening here I've got a lot
going on mott I got a lot going on but
when there's things like that going on I
want to get into the trenches I left a
comment Gabe I would love to Yap with
you on this you have do you have AOL
Instant Messenger Gabe then um who's
Gabe k Mont let's link that up Gabe k on
Twitter said sure I'm um gangis Gabe on
aim I hit up Gabe and I said dude hey
man I'm so sorry I'm coming off wrong
too i wish i didn't he writes back it's
funny i was actually just watching your
most recent episode of wine library TV
when i heard from you which is pretty
cool something's like he doesn't totally
hate me I put wild I'm sorry I said some
things he said hey man it's really not
you I don't think I don't really get I
didn't really get you before big omaha
and now i know you're a real guy not
just an online celebrity-type but i
think people look at you as someone with
more answers or more suggestions when
you're set wouldn't you yourself tell
people to follow their dreams a bit of a
wd duality excuse me between what you
say and what people interpret I think
that could be true um gay but same token
I do believe that um you know I don't
have the answers and everybody knows
themselves and I do believe it's passion
and I do believe in the details which is
why I wrote the book in the details of
how to build that brand get in the
trenches by the way why this video I
know right now I'm in the midst of a
good video I seen I know people are
watching this right now and like oh crap
oh that I mean you know what I really
liked though and what really compelled
me to UM um do this as I said hey would
you mind if I do the whole TV thing
right now unless he said yeah go ahead
on how to handle constructive
conversation he goes I think that's a
great idea the world needs more of this
absolutely see here's the problem when
somebody says what Gabe said about me a
lot of people get emotional in the world
of business if you put yourself out
there you can't get emotional you're in
an unemotional game and if you find
yourself as an emotional character
you're gonna have some interesting times
navigating through the world we live in
you put yourself out there you have to
expect people to have opinions and a lot
of times they're right and sometimes
they're wrong and sometimes it's in
between I think this almost proud
in between play right but what I love is
that Gabe and I through technology are
probably in a place now where we like
each other so much more and this didn't
have to be a flame war and I didn't have
to go on Twitter like I've seen a lot of
people who've got a lot of followers
pushing the cloud around like ass
Junkers I'm trying to fix up my language
a little bit you know the baby's coming
mind I'm thinking about this I'm like oh
my god I don't think I want to curse
anymore and oh my god I think I want all
the videos down what I do a lot of
people saying oh I'm gonna look nobody
should like this person unfollow this
person let's tear down this restaurant I
mean people get a little head of
themselves this didn't need to be a
situation where I said you know hey
veiniacs kill Gabe you know who I am
this is situation where i need to
one-on-one go out and find Gabe like we
did and it got some really nice place
and I really respect gave her his
thoughts I understand where he's coming
from and I'm not doing a good enough job
to articulate to Gabe or anybody else
that has that mindset so I'm going to
work on that I learned something from it
at the meantime I was following along
and Alex I said I rode out to Alex
before that other than being a hell of a
Salesman I wrote something nice like I
hope people care about let me actually
look since I'm gonna miss the video i
wrote Alex to be honest I didn't totally
oh I'm sorry Alex I'm hoping that's the
fact that I care about people and I
hustle and help whenever I can and give
back and I don't take myself too serious
Alex road um to that I respect that I
really would have loved to hear you
crush the question about net neutrality
at big omaha but you dodged it which I
did but he might have not known why I
wrote Alex to be honest I didn't totally
understand it I got distracted and
didn't hear it in full what was it you
want to go on ustream there was a
question and I guess it was net
neutrality I don't even know that
something happened either I heard
something I was spoke can't remember
exactly what happened but for a split
second which is super rare for me I lost
focus of the question and because I
didn't know it you know I was like uh I
was gonna say repeat it I don't know
which is usually my move I don't know
what happened i thought i might have
caught it I got caught I was half
pregnant and so he thought I dodged it
but I really really didn't and then I
said can do you stream and Alex said
still at the 95 925 so I can't use dream
but I'll shoot you an email I feel like
an ass for being critical you really do
care I don't want to make him feel like
it
I said Alex you are not an ass because
you know what everybody can have
opinions that's what's awesomeness
that's why my family left communist
Russia you know to live in a world
that's extremism about this stuff um
this is just a really good example about
no matter how busy you are by the way
this is not bull crapping mot that's uh
that's um I'm not showing the number
let's move up right here my man 1100
email Oh lemono 352 on red um let's look
at the calendar what the calendar look
at the calendar bot five o'clock leave
office you getting this mom leave office
what's that moving mouse 5pm leave
office I have a 505 call about a keynote
that's gonna pay me money it's now 518
and the reason i didn't get there is
because I'm caring it's not about
closing the next deal or you know this
sat or the other thing it's about really
giving a crap and using the tools that
are in place today because a year ago
three years ago more likely three years
ago there's people out there to have
opinions about you and you had no way to
address them today you do and I've dress
them and I care and I think that's a
difference maker and and that's that see
you later this video was good
you